one of the biggest issues of unhappiness
in 2022 in america and beyond is the
complete and utter lack of
accountability
i'm passionate about accountability i
think the unbelievable vulnerability
in our ecosystem right now is people not
being accountable for themselves
we are now in the finger-pointing
generation it's your fault it's their
fault this institution's fault it's this
human being's fault people think
technology's changing us i think it's
exposing us this thing is your gateway
to get out of the thing that you
complain about but people would rather
complain about how it is than put in the
work
when you go into blame game you are
vulnerable people would rather default
into why they can't than putting in the
actions that allow them to can i am
remarkably stunned by the lack of
accountability in our society do you
know how liberating it is when you
realize everything's your fault it gets
real [ __ ] good out here something
i've been thinking a lot about is i'm
asking people to be more accountable but
i have to be careful because a lot of
people's version of intaking
accountability is beating themselves up
just stop judging yourself everybody
else is doing it for you already
everybody just wants to point fingers 24
[ __ ] hours a day and tell you why
everybody else is doing things wrong the
system that person this just [ __ ]
firing fingers 24 7 without a thumb and
a mirror ever figure out what your
[ __ ] thing is and stop making [ __ ]
[ __ ] excuses i just want it so bad
for you i want it bad for you
zero accountability it has been
completely eliminated we must put
accountability on a pedestal
if you're like well gary [ __ ] you i grew
up in a family that was very pessimistic
and this is what it is well then what do
you want then go to therapy right like
do something fight for it fight to be
happy
listen to positive [ __ ] that's a funny
game
miraculous thing happens when you cut
out your most pessimistic friend you
become more optimistic news alert you're
deciding what life actually is it is
your subjective call
[Music]
this is a game of perspective
i don't understand how we don't
understand that there's a very big
difference between i'm accountable
and
it's my fault and i suck i'm a piece of
[ __ ]
it's perspective you know i think about
world war ii i think about so many
genocides i think about the people and
the millions of people around the world
that don't have clean water
every day i'm not capable of dwelling
because of you know gratitude
accountability you know like what am i
gonna do about it
and perspective and so i'm
what do i say i say we should be
thankful that we can even have this
conversation health over everything
and uh just perspective man it's just
perspective
[Music]
[Music]
my friends do you know how rare it is to
have a life
the odds right now currently that
science accepts for the odds of actually
being alive is 400 trillion
one life baby one life
one life
one life one life one
lack of
accountability this is the key to the
whole thing
the mindset of accountability is what
makes you win makes you happy whether
it's true or not
got it
the thought of taking on responsibility
for everything that's not working
is the win whether you're right or wrong
[Music]
you